er sich eine sehr glückliche spd und
jetzt spricht
zwei wahlsiegerin und ein wahlsieger und
alle zusammen haben zustande gebracht
was wir lange angestrebt haben nämlich
eine starke sozialdemokratische partei
die den auftrag kriegt die regierung zu
führen in berlin in schwerin in
mecklenburg vorpommern und auch hier in
der bundesrepublik deutschland
die wählerinnen und wähler haben auch
sehr klar gesprochen sie haben gesagt
wer die nächste regierung bilden soll
sie hat drei parteien gestärkt die
sozialdemokratische partei die grünen
und die fdp und deshalb ist das der
sichtbare auftrag den die bürgerinnen
und bürger dieses landes formuliert
haben diese drei sollen auch die nächste
regierung führen
und auch das kann und muss hier gesagt
werden cdu und csu haben nicht nur
erheblich an stimmen verloren sondern
sie haben tatsächlich auch die
botschafter bürgern und bürger bekommen
sie sollen jetzt nicht mehr in der
regierung sein sondern in die opposition
gehen
der auftrag an uns ist jetzt auch das zu
tun was die bürgern und bürger sich
wünschen nicht eigene befindlichkeiten
in den vordergrund zu stellen sondern
eine gute regierung zu führen die die
wichtigsten weichenstellungen für die
20er jahre auf den weg bringt wir es
schaffen dass mehr respekt in unserer
gesellschaft herrscht wie wir es
schaffen die industrielle modernisierung
unseres landes zustande zu kriegen und
wie wir es schaffen dass wir den
menschengemachten klimawandel aufhalten
drei große aufgaben die noch
verstärkt werden durch die aufgabe
deutschlands dafür zu sorgen dass wir
ein starkes souveränes europa bekommen
wenn man die programme aller parteien
die von den wählern und wählern
zusätzliche stimmen bekommen haben
anschaut dann sieht man dass es genügend
schnittmengen gibt dies auch zustande zu
bringen aber jetzt ist pragmatismus und
führungskunst gefragt und es geht
natürlich auch darum dass man mit guter
ruhe und guter klarheit das zustande
bringt auch das erwarten die bürgerinnen
und bürger von uns
ich bin sehr dankbar und sehr berührt
von der großen zustimmung für mich und
für die sozialdemokratische partei und
wir werden das was die bürgerinnen und
bürger uns als auftrag gegeben haben
umsetzen schönen dank
vielen dank liebe olaf liebe franziska
liebe saskia lieber norbert liebe
genossinnen und genossen liebe
unterstützung und unterstützer liebe
gäste zunächst möchte ich ganz herzlich
olaf scholz gratulieren und unserer spd
in deutschland zu diesem wahlsieg es war
eine spannende bundestagswahl die
bürgerinnen und bürger mussten erstmals
darüber entscheiden wer zukünftig das
land führen soll und das ergebnis ist
klar die spd ist wahlsieger die
bürgerinnen und bürger haben olaf scholz
ihr vertrauen ausgesprochen und wir
wissen aus allen befragungen die
bürgerinnen und bürger wollen dass olaf
scholz der nächste bundeskanzler von
deutschland wird und das muss er auch
werden
[Applaus]
und deshalb liegt auch bei ihm und der
spd ganz klar
der regierungsauftrag deutschland
braucht eine gute stabile regierung für
wirtschaft soziales und umwelt und
deutschland braucht vor allem einen
kanzler der das vertrauen der
bevölkerung bekommen hat und der es kann
und der zukünftige kanzler soll olaf
scholz sein
mein glückwunsch geht auch an franziska
giffey malu dreyer und ich haben uns
immer gewünscht dass wir im kreise der
ministerpräsidenten nicht allein nur
zwei frauen blei bleiben und ich freue
mich sehr dass wir zukünftig mit drei
sozialdemokratischen ministerpräsidenten
in dieser mpk gute politik machen liebe
franziska herzlichen glückwunsch zum
sieg auch der berliner spd
[Applaus]
und ich freue mich natürlich dass die
bürger also dass die wahlsieger bei der
spd hier ja so rund 500 meter entfernt
vom studio in der spd-parteizentrale
wird sich gefeiert von ein bisschen
unglücklich dass alle nur in der ganzen
rede hier blumenstrauß die ganz kleinen
aber so ist das leben insgesamt läuft
sich ganz glücklich seitdem war seit dem
wahlsieg bei der spd ist muss man sagen
der olaf scholz eigentlich hat den
überragenden wahlsieg gestern gefeiert
wirkt irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen
zurückhaltend bisschen gekniffen in der
berliner runde gestern abend das muss
uns unser bild vize paul ronzheimer
erklären schönen guten morgen auch dir
nach einer langen wahlnacht und
vermutlich sehr sehr kurzen schlaf in
der nacht die spd hat jetzt trotz
alledem eine schwierige situation was
glaubst du jetzt der erste schachzug
sein den olaf scholz heute macht geil
wir haben gerade den ersten schachzug
gesehen denn nachdem olaf scholz gestern
weg gelöst ist wie alex gemacht hat und
auch nicht mal kapiert hat wie sehr
gewonnen hat ist er jetzt auf angriff er
hat gesagt wir haben gewonnen wir haben
den regierungsauftrag und die union soll
es fälle ist in die opposition das ist
das lauteste härteste was wir von olaf
scholz seit wahlsieg 18 uhr gehört haben
und man hat auch ein bisschen darauf
gewartet denn die spd droht jetzt das
weg zu kennen was sie gerade gewonnen
haben also sie müssen darauf achten dass
sie jetzt die fdp die grünen irgendwie
einfangen dass sie das ding den sagt wie
man so schön sagt zu machen können denn
momentan was man aus den politischen
basen hört aus den parteizentralen
ich habe das handy dabei was man da hört
ist na ja das könnte auch richtung
jamaika gehen das könnte auch in eine
ganz andere richtung geht obwohl olaf
scholz diese wahl gewonnen hat und in
der spd hat man pure panik dass armin
laschet und christian lindner und dann
vielleicht zusammen mit robert habeck
den sack zumachen können ohne die spd
und da muss er jetzt rein aber das ist
nicht seine stärke das haben wir auch da
gesehen wieso ist er nicht noch
offensiver warum hat er nicht drauf
warum sagt denn ich habe gewonnen so
gerd schröder mäßig sich der einzusetzen
sagen kreuz und ja kommt hier bin ich
wir sind wir sind kanzler sozusagen
müsste er heute morgen eigentlich sagen
[Musik]